kind of an odd thing happened in my
house last night everyone's okay but
this is a personal thing in my life this
huge tree fell over in our backyard and
just shattered and just scattered limbs
and stuff it was kind of scary he's
weird
oh you know what we had that happen a
while ago in a storm and and you're left
with like a big tree in your yard and
you don't know what to do with it so I
actually I hired this service to come
and chop it up and they did a really
great job they just came over and take
care of it yeah yeah that sounds like I
could use their services what were they
called I forget their name they had a
jingle though is a chop chop chopper tea
I can't remember exactly it was a
terrible jingle though hey Andy that was
my service the chop chop guys right
right the chop chop guys you guys did a
great job thanks but I can't believe you
didn't like our jingle hit it if a tree
has fallen in your backyard
don't be crestfallen it's not that hard
to contact the guys can chop it up and
you'll be surprised on how low our
prices are the prices are measured to
the size of the tree for example a
larger tree would be more expensive you
don't have to sing the whole jingle it's
okay we're the chop chop guys chop chop
chop buddy
chop chop guys chop chop chop buddy
just call the number on your screen 800
charp
3 okay wait a minute wait a minute man
Andy you are not kidding that's a
terrible jingle yeah sounds like your
jingle needs an operation oh my god I'm
the jingle doctor I bet I can write you
a better jingle my friend really sure
just check out my commercial if you
advertise your business and do what to
use a song I can help you write
attendant won't take much time
find the jingle proctologist the tingle
proctologist the jingle proctologist
jingle proctologist the jingle
proctologist a dingo dingo dingo dingo
[Music]
no you people are crazy your jingle was
even worse than the first guys yeah and
you said that you're the jingle doctor
and in the commercial you repeatedly
referred to yourself as the jingle
proctologist the word proctologist flows
better no hmm those jingles were both
mundane you need something magical oh
Jesus
okay so let me guess you're the jingle
wizard right yes I am and here's my
commercial
call 800 1 1 1 1 1 big 801 gonna be 800
[Music]
801 World War II will be 800
one one beat
[Music]
[Applause]
that is absolutely the worst one yet
damn you're actually right guys he's
right we're a bunch of failures yeah
tonin's right we've embarrassed
ourselves let's leave it once come on
I'm sorry guys you don't you don't have
to leave no you don't need to ask us for
a 4-time Conan we're gonna leave
[Applause]
you